deux des neuf otages français devait
être libéré au liberia suis mieux qu'une
confirmation de ces libérations
l'organisation de la justice
révolutionnaire de veut les remettre à
une délégation diplomatique contenant
leur est pas dans ta française syrien et
algériens mais aucune confirmation
service minimum télévisé sur les trois
chaînes de service public pourra tester
contre le projet de réforme de
l'audiovisuel de monsieur léotard
d'autres services minimum possible la
semaine prochaine coluche meurt vive
coluche l'accident mortel de michel
colucci hier a suscité une très grande
émotion en france
le monde politique salue le comédien en
vainqueur mais que vont devenir les
restos du coeur bonsoir je pense à vous
annoncer une mauvaise nouvelle c'est à
dire la libération de deux des neuf
otages français du liban
pour l'instant aucune confirmation c'est
donc peut-être qu'il faut dire la nasse
que nous devions faire ce soir était
venue d'un espoir donnée par
l'organisation justice révolutionnaire
qui disait qu'elle allait remettre deux
des neuf otages français cet après midi
à beyrouth cas de l'hôtel beau rivage
prudence de nouvelles précises car on a
pas trace de ces deux otages français
qui seraient libres à la ména location
en france inter nous explique les
conditions dans lesquelles cela s'est
passé à communiquer à l'enfant dans les
24 heures la libération ne peuvent pas
français
le texte est signé en réalisation de la
justice révolutionnaire celle qui le 14
mars dernier avait revendiqué
l'enlèvement mais l'équipe antenne 2
dans l'après midi un autre coup de
téléphone petty le lieu l'hôtel beau
rivage et leurs 19 heures le telle
résidence des officiers présents ici à
beyrouth est investi par une trentaine
de journalistes qui l'attendent comme
ans que l'enfant saluer avant l'heure le
chargé d'affaires algeria monsieur
assène bouquet miss heiva l'hôtel
protégé par deux gardes du corps
à 19 heures précises les peureux
surveillance de l'ambassade de france
orange devant le goût virage
le responsable de la sécurité
d'ambassades entre dans lequel elle
entretient avec le diplomate algérien
il faut un peu aller retour entre la
voiture aux vitres fumées bac elle se
trouve l'ambassadeur de france ce qui
tend vers nous
l avant d'accompagner le chargé
d'affaires algeria aux côtés de
christian glacée de voiture démarre en
trombe font 300 mètres s'arrête près
d'une mercedes podium défense de cette
mercedes pour s'engouffrer dans les
voitures de l'ambassade de france qui
redémarre
il est 7 heures le cortège revient
devant l'hôtel beau rivage les lauriers
si rien exclure les journalistes pendant
qu'un hélicoptère français se posent à
jonnier infecteur chrétiens à 40 km au
nord de beyrouth ouest après leurs deux
rendez vous à 8h30
laura valeur de france christian vaisse
et avec l'ambassade à martap la seule à
l'éminent guînes vous donner ce qu'il a
vécu messieurs place à beyrouth nous
venons de parler directement par
téléphone avec l'un des collaborateurs
de l'ambassadeur de france monsieur
christian graeff l'ambassade at il dit
est resté 45 minutes à l'intérieur
l'hôtel beau rivage
en l'absence de tout contact il est
reparti pour sa résidence personne n'est
monté dans sa voiture ce qui contredit
légèrement le compte rendu de la mine à
personne ne monte dans sa voiture sur le
trajet du retour il est arrivé seul à sa
résidence là dessus tout le monde est
d'accord
l'ambassade de france à beyrouth me
confirme donc pas la libération il ya ce
mot terry du chargé d'affaires de
l'ambassade de france à beyrouth
rien est le mot qui résume tous viennent
nous dire donne ce diplomate français
j'ajouterai cette déclaration faite à l'
agence france-presse
croyez moi c'est du cinéma avec un
responsable français de l'ambassade
et puis monsieur chirac qui est s'est
contenté de dire il ya quelques minutes
l'annnonce de la libération n'est
malheureusement pas confirmé monsieur
chirac qui suit personnellement la
sphère d'un cinglé de l'hôtel matignon
depuis ce matin alors elle doit à leers
tout a commencé donc ce matin avec la
l'annoncé par l'organisation de la
justice révolutionnaire de la libération
de ses deux otages c'est cette
organisation qui avait enlevé le 8 mars
86 et type d'antenne 2 et 1 explique un
bon gars là on les relâche parce que la
politique de la france au proche orient
g parce qu'il y ait vu les médiations
humanitaire du hezbollah iraniens des
algériens et puis les syriens alors il y
a donc quand même des raisons d'espérer
oui on avait cette fois de bonnes
raisons n'ont pas dit croire fermement
parce que l'expérience nous a appelé à
être très prudents nous en tout cas
d'espérer et d'espérer parce que les
termes du communiqué la nuit dernière
sont tout à fait crédibles
d'abord dans l'énoncé de ceux qui ont
servi d'intermédiaire la nation du
hezbollah autrement dit l'iran le
président assad donc la syrie et d'îles
communiqué nos amis algériens l'algérie
entre parenthèses avait eu un rôle de
premier plan dans la sphère des otages
américains de téhéran deuxième point la
justification de ces libérations part je
cite les signes d'un changement de la
politique française au proche orient
allusion donc aux négociations en cours
avec l'iran sur la dette
eurodif c'est bien avancé et surtout
allusion au départ du territoire
français de radjavi l'opposant iranien
il ya deux semaines et avec promesse de
libérer plus tard les deux autres otages
des liquides antenne 2 si la france
continue à faire preuve de bonne volonté
donc de quoi espérer c'est vrai espérer
aussi que cette promesse de libération à
18 heures
si elle n'a pas encore eu lieu n'est
qu'une question de durée ou par non à
une question de minutes
le quai d'orsay c'est à dire le
ministère des relations extérieures
confirme que l'ambassadeur de france est
rentrée dans sa résidence sans les
otages
il ya aussi peut-être l'espoir d'une
piste des otages seraient partis vers
damas on verra peut-être dans les
minutes qui viennent nous informerons
bien sûr nos prochaines éditions
demain aujourd'hui c'était service
minimum sur les trois chaînes de
télévision de service public un même
programme pour la une la deux et la
trois ce journal je dois vous le passez
ise a été préparé par des personnels
techniciens et journalistes requis ou
non grévistes la télé étaient en grève à
l'appel de l'ensemble des syndicats pfa
tester contre le projet de privatisation
de tf1 et de la forme de l'audiovisuel
public la semaine prochaine il peut y
avoir d'autres mouvements de grève
malgré l'affirmation du ministère de la
culture de sa volonté de dialogue le
point sur les revendications syndicales
et la mobilisation des personnels de
télévision gaël monk
c'est par une pensée pour leurs
confrères détenus au liban que les
personnels de l'audiovisuel ont ouvert
ce matin leur assemblée générale à la
bourse du travail sont 500 salariés
environ réunis à l'appel des syndicats
majoritaires cfdt cgt et snj mobilisés
et très déterminés à poursuivre leur
mouvement contre le projet de loi par
tous les moyens
nous prenons les dispositions pour
quadriller la semaine pour agir à chaque
fois que cela sera nécessaire
pour l'instant les préavis du 25 et 26
juin sont maintenues mais les personnels
ont voté à l'unanimité une motion qui
garantirait la retransmission du mondial
à condition qu'ils aient la possibilité
d'expliquer leur mouvement à l'antenne
réponse pour tout cela la semaine
prochaine à tf1 la grève semble avoir
été assez largement suivie d'autant que
pour la première fois les syndicats fo
et cftc puissant sur la chaîne s'était
joint au mouvement
mais ils sont en désaccord pour la suite
nous avons donc
donc nous avons donc facettes cette
grève aujourd'hui mais les métiers de
vous dire que l'on sera pas celle du 25
août 26 comme l'a dit françois wernert
pas cet été de la cgt parce qu'on pense
que là dans le mondial on va se mettre
le public complètement à dos et c'est
pas sérieux
190 journalistes de tf1 ont souscrit
depuis quelques jours à la création
d'une société de rédacteur pour veiller
à l'indépendance et à la qualité de
l'information pour que la rédaction
existe en tant que tel on regroupant
toutes ses sensibilités et qu'elle
puisse être un interlocuteur face au
gouvernement à la commission nationale
communication et libertés et les
candidats à la reprise
par ailleurs le mouvement la télé et
hans organise plus de 90 comité en
province se sont mises en place pour
l'instant ils répondent aux courriers
diffuse des milliers de badges et de
cartes postales
prépare une manifestation qu'ils
espèrent très importante pour la rentrée
au pérou le à tablissements de la ddt
dans les prisons la capitale lima ses
fesses en détail la révolte des détenus
politiques accusés de terrorisme est
soupçonné d'appartenir au sentier
lumineux a été réprimée dans le sang
il y aurait plusieurs centaines de morts
des commandos suicides ont tenté cet
après-midi de troubler l'organisation de
la conférence de l'internationale
socialiste
rennie halima commenté à philippe gassot
ce qui était visé c'était ce building le
crillon où s'ouvrait aujourd'hui le 17e
congrès de l'internationale socialiste
kalima ouvert par le président alan
garcia guérir on pense tout de suite au
sentier lumineux avaient installé un
mortier sur la terrasse d'un immeuble
c'est au moment où le premier obus est
introduit dans le canon que le mortier
explose tuant une jeune femme 400
personnes venues de tous les continents
se trouvait au crillon cet attentat
manqué intervient le jour même où
l'armée les primes dans un bain de sang
la révolte avec arme de trois prisons
péruviennes les guérilleros du sentier
lumineux réclament le maintien du statut
de prisonnier politique l'armée attaque
le prisonnier se défendre pied à pied
sur les 700 révolte et la moitié sera
tué une prison tient encore seul del
tronto appelé aussi l'île du diable
l'armée dynamite une partie du bâtiment
tandis que les mutins se réfugient dans
les soutes et les forces de m attends là
présent larmes au pied que la fin et
fasse sortir
il est probable que le président
péruvien alan garcia sera tenu
d'expliquer au congrès les raisons du
massacre plus de 300 morts les arts est
si on continue au chili la police de
pinochet intervient quotidiennement pour
interpeller dans les milieux
universitaires une certaine de personnes
ont été emprisonnées hier
essentiellement des enseignants en
pèlerinage walesa de nouveau convoqué
par la police six militants de
solidarité accusé d'avoir imprimé des
bulletins du syndicalisme ont été
condamnés à des peines de prison
on a fait du sud où la ceinture nous
empêche de savoir ce qui se passe
réellement les violences continuent six
personnes ont été tuées dont un enfant à
soweto
un groupe de défense des droits civiques
en afrique du sud affirme avoir été
saisie de plus de 1000 cas de
disparition me remet un peu observé qui
faisait la grève de la faim devant
l'ambassade de roumanie
harry a obtenu satisfaction sa famille
est arrivée en france avec passeport et
visa conforme
dominique torrès promenade familiale pop
up sergei le gréviste de la faim qui au
bout de vingt jours a eu gain de cause
ou presque sa soeur et son beau frère
vient d'arriver mais sans leurs enfants
observez votre soeur qui est ici
maintenant de très touchés vous ayez
fait vingt jours de grève de la faim
pour la faire venir avec son mari oui
moi seul et très touché et comme son
mari parce qu'ils ont appris même
harmonie avec le post kyoto et
sinon demain là
vous aviez déjà fait une grève de la
faim pour faire venir votre femme je
crois ya quelques années oui j'avais
c'est la grèce
de la faim pendant picchu 1983 et pour
sortir ma famille et les enfants là
progrès l'élan tirer aussi et je suis
content et les enfants ils sont restés
en roumanie visons le montage à
condition que
la nuit
vous parlez français voulait rester en
france oui oui on en tunisie le combat
du destour le parti au pouvoir doit
examiner de nouveau la succession du
président bourguiba et monsieur
bourguiba contre toute attente a bien
désigné celui qu'il a qualifié de son
fils l'actuel premier ministre monsieur
mohamed ali commentaires gérard ine
mohamed sahli a donc poussé un grand
soupir de soulagement l'épée de damoclès
qui pesait sur lui a apparemment disparu
habib bourguiba devant le congrès du
parti socialiste destourien au pouvoir
depuis trente ans l'a confirmé au poste
de premier ministre et donc
implicitement désigné comme son
successeur
c'est un peu une surprise le premier
ministre avait connu récemment plusieurs
revers certains de ses très proches
collaborateurs avaient été mis sur la
touche et l'important portefeuille de
l'intérieur lui avait même été retiré
par le combattant suprême
la confirmation de mohammed ali est donc
à la fois une victoire pour le premier
ministre mais aussi un échec pour le
clan de la femme d'habib bourguiba qui
est parti de tunisie en claquant la
porte
déjà une campagne avait fait valser des
têtes dans le monde des affaires
tunisiens touchant les personnalités
proches de les pouces présidentielle
mais mohamed sahli n'a pas que des amis
il devra résister aux intrigues le jeu
de la succession est calme et disait un
député mais le jeu continue et syndicats
de chercheurs entame protester contre
les coupes sont réalisés dans les
budgets les modifications des règles
d'élection cnrs les syndicats de
chercheurs annoncent une journée
d'action le 24 juin prochain pour ce
même jour le 24 juin la cgc appellent à
manifester contre la décision
ministérielle de ne plus financer les
chantiers navals
ils vont gattaz à maubeuge estimé au nom
du cnpf que ceux qui pensent qu'on
pourrait maintenir les chantiers navals
font un beau rêve à l'hôtel matignon
jacques chirac déjeuné avec
industrielle du midi la situation des
chantiers de la norme aide à la scène et
à la ciotat a été évoquée et de son côté
jean claude gaudin le député udf
président du conseil régional de places
côte d'azur a souhaité que le
gouvernement conserve un chantier naval
sur la façade méditerranéenne
enfin c'est le 9 juillet que les
négociations entre les partenaires
sociaux commenceront au siège du cnpf
tous les syndicats y compris la cgt
seront présents il s'agit de prévoir les
aménagements nécessaires après le vote
de la suppression de l'autorisation
préalable de licenciement
plusieurs opérations de police hier à
paris dans le nord et en banlieue
parisienne opération de police à
l'initiative du ministre de la justice
et avec la brigade des stupéfiants 55
personnes ont été gardés à vue à propos
de la drogue et de ce fléau la face le
juge bernard rey interrogée par hervé
brusini sans évoquer tout le problème
des réseaux internationaux de trafic de
dresde évoque ce qui le concerne lui a
tant que juge ses terres le problème de
la répression de ce trafic de drogue
pendant longtemps que tu es content
quand on prenait un gramme de drogue
maintenant nous sommes sur les affaires
qui porte sur 2 kg nous ne remontons
plus les filières nous attaquons au
niveau de ce que j'appelle le point le
dos c'est à dire au niveau des dealers
et des grossistes et dans les temps de
la garde à vue
nous remontons maintenant même à partir
de l'essonne jusqu'à la hollande
je pense que ces méthodes ou peu les
apprendre aux policiers on peut les
apprendre aux gendarmes
on peut les développer actuellement en
france d'autre part je suis frappé par
le fait que les toxicomanes maintenant
leur dogme est en train de pardon c'est
avec des choses veulent et qu'ils la
paient un
votre autoradio votre magnétoscope
dérobé lors d'un cambriolage
les papiers volés à une femme quand on
lui arrache son sac à main les bijoux
arracher une femme dans le métro
il existe tout un réseau de recel
le
dealer maintenant on n'a plus besoin
d'argent il le remet de la drogue contre
les choses volet est lui à ce qu'on
appelle son fourgon qui fait partir vers
le grand les grands réseaux du recel les
choses vont aller je crois qu'il
faudrait être impitoyable et développer
considérablement l'action au niveau du
recel
rien ne le laissait indifférent coluche
je vais utiliser son talent et sa
célébrité pour pousser des coups de
gueule dérangeant depuis hier le
personnel politique à l'exception
notable de jean marie le pen salue
l'artiste sur les circonstances de
l'accident un coluche un témoin affirme
aujourd'hui qu'il ne portait pas de
casque
les enquêteurs cherchent également à
savoir à quelle vitesse roulait coluche
mais au fond qu'importe maintenant le
coeur de coluche a été transféré
aujourd'hui dans l'aïr dans la soirée à
grasse et puis aujourd'hui d'une part un
convoi funèbre il a pris la direction de
paris
les obsèques de coluche couette avoir
lieu à moins rouge en région parisienne
coluche est mort que l'on devenir les
restos du coeur et ce d'ici qui ont faim
que reste-t-il maintenant dans les têtes
de ceux qui riait temps en l'écoutant
bruno le dreff roland sicard et avez
vous signé
nicolette magique me souffle il suçait
connu chez marc et moi je viens je
n'étais pas très content
sur les gens sans béquilles ces bêtes
qui sont morts c'est tout la version de
parler de coluche la façon que les super
bass et la façon de tous les jours on a
beau dire de paris c'est au 1 et ben
c'est pour ça qu'on aime on a
l'impression de parler on a même
problème la passeuse s'habille en homme
des gags on aime on aime c'est tim mamy
maintenant tirer quant à qui ces
différents lots c'est vrai si mario en
mettrons non ses 51 6
j'étais d'abord puis pousse le dos à ces
liens imex on touche à s'être alors moi
j'ai rien je le repousse à la normale un
certain mais je sabine fait part que le
talent est clos chantôme armand il fait
alors notre jeu
yauba jusqu'au n'est pas par exemple
aurait mis au point le costa puis
pensons à la bombe est un grand coup de
poing quand je les nie ces faits aïcha
retombe dans la gueule
parisé gonflé rien ta vie ta joue
il a dit que nous demeurions mieux bien
ce qui lui a d'ailleurs qu'il était au
tour d'aller à la mecque qui commence à
l'âge que les gens comme ils n'avaient
pas les conducteurs ou ailleurs
ni comminatoire voulu dire que on est
tous égaux
c'est quand même dégueulasse qu'ils
soient morts pour ce que j'ai bien peur
ces restaurants du coeur je termine
misère misère
et c'est toujours sur les pauvres gens
que tu t'acharnes obstinément misère
misère
ça sera donc toujours les [ __ ] qui
nous bouffent rond le caviar sur le dos
misère misère
je viens depuis quinze jours seulement
mais depuis quinze jours oui j'ai mieux
manger mais j'ai plutôt que j'ai
énormément difficulté actuellement et
qui sont qui sont pour manger vous ça
m'a beaucoup aidé c'est bien pour moi
qui ai pour les vaccins on avait émis
l'hypothèse de continuer les restaurants
du coeur dès septembre prochain 70 86 on
pensait le faire d'ailleurs en
permanence avec d'autres structures
n'envisageons certainement d'autres
possibilités mais sur son catalyseur
principal qui était coluche on ne sait
pas très bien si ça va marcher
moi ce que je pense c'est que le
meilleur hommage que pourrait faire
inconnue c'est que les gens continuent à
donner si lorsqu'ils entendront que les
restaurants du coeur reprennent
je marche je suis là
il m'a légué
les bras
une histoire dont on se souvient par
exemple
et j'ai pas le noir que tu as manqué lui
qui en occident puisqu'il allegro
sûr que
je
la police a annoncé la découverte du
corps à paris d'une nouvelle vieille
dame morte assassinée dans le 5e
arrondissement la victime avait les
pieds et les poings liés
c'est la dixième personne âgée assassiné
à son domicile depuis le début de cette
année 86 demain à 10 heures 50 en direct
sur antenne 2 journal à 19h30 les
français seront opposés aux brésiliens
pour les quarts de finale de la coupe du
monde pour mexique antenne 2 à jouer les
espions est allé observer les brésiliens
à l'entraînement commentaires lionel
chamoulaud séance de travail pour
l'équipe du brésil
le sujet les bleus
le match france italie les regards
intéressés voire impressionné le visage
fermé
l'équipe de france est respecté mais
attaquer ce qui aurait dû être une
finale j'espère que le pays qui se
qualifiera sera champion du monde ici à
mexico en battant largement la pologne
le brésil a retrouvé son âme un jeu
d'attaqué un jeu de fait d'ailleurs au
brésil le football c'est la fête même à
l'entraînement
la plupart des sélectionnés brésiliens
ont commencé à jouer ici sur la plage
c'est là qu'ils ont tout appris le geste
le plaisir l'endurance et c'est
incomparable technique qui fait des
joueurs au maillot jaune des
footballeurs inimitable jeu en mouvement
c'est cette façon de conserver le ballon
de la faire tourner et de faire de faire
commencer à fatiguer l'adversaire mais
c'est trois qu'ils font on est là
voyez quelqu'un les voir jouer je crois
qu'il est revenu avec des enchaînements
en 82 en espagne tout le monde a
regretté que la france et le brésil ne
se rencontrent pas ce quart de finale
réparé l'injustice
quoi qu'il arrive demain ce sera une
immense soirée de football de plaisir
entre les deux équipes les plus
attrayants de la compétition pour le
football france brésil c'est un grand
bonheur
ce sera à 19h50 sur antenne 2 demain il
y à un tiercé demain si les pronostics
proposé par querrey base le prix de
courteille à saint-cloud cousu d'or le
11 bis de 13 france freestyle 14 tossing
15 guardian ar c'est le 6 cénarius le 5
faraco le 8 et sollicitude le neuf
voilà pour les pronostics de pied agace
les prévisions de la météo leur a
boussier et puisque demain sera le
premier jour de l'été officiel nous
allons fêter ça avec un temps de saison
tout du moins en ce qui concerne les
températures en attendant regardons la
photo satellite prise cet après midi par
météo ça qu'il faisait relativement beau
sur la majeure partie du pays mais il y
avait un petit peu partout des foyers
orageux demain ça va empirer avec
l'arrivée de cette perturbation il était
déjà là hier elle aurait dû arriver un
beaucoup plus vite mais elle est bloquée
alors elle se retrouvera demain
uniquement sur les côtes de l'atlantique
ailleurs un temps toujours orageux
carrie la carte du temps que prévu pour
demain vous allez voir les orages
presque partout sauf sur l'est du pays
là il fera beau un ciel clair du soleil
pas de problème tout comme sur les côtes
de la méditerranée est encore ailleurs
c'est à dire sur la majeure partie de la
france
temps lourd avec des brumes peut-être
même dès brouillard le matin et surtout
des risques d'orage toujours vers la
même heure c'est à dire entre 4h30 et 7
heures du soir
à ce moment-là et de rage pourront
devenir violent surtout sur le sud du
pays et puis dans la soirée arrivée
d'une nouvelle petite perturbation
aggravation nuageuse avec des risque
d'ondée sur la bretagne un petit peu sur
les pays de la loire
côté température par contre alors là
c'est celle est écrit cas de le dire
des températures qui presque partout
atteindront les 30° 30 même 31 degrés
sur la majeure partie du pays quelques
maps 9° évidemment non qu'entre 29 et 31
degrés ya pas beaucoup de différence
sauf sur brest 21 degrés seulement si
l'arrivée de cette nouvelle perturbation
temps un petit peu plus frais alors que
sur joli le reste du pays 31 degrés à
agen 31 degrés à toulouse 31 degrés
sur toute la région la région lyonnaise
les alpes temps chaud chaud et lourdes
sachez aussi que sur le reste de
l'europe demain il fera 24 degrés à
londres et 30° à l'arceau est évidemment
encore notre agenda
on termine demain sera le samedi 21
joueurs le savaient se lèvera à 5h40 se
couchera 21h56 est un des jours les plus
longs de l'été le vrai plus long ce
qu'est aujourd'hui ce sera la salle
raoul et ce sera effectivement aussi
l'été enfin je vais appelle la formation
la plus un platane de ce vendredi s
avère que l'organisation justice
révolutionnaire au liban avait annoncé
que deux otages deux des neuf otages
français seraient libérés deux sans
doute de l'équipe d'antenne de rendez
vous était donné à l'hôtel beau rivage à
beyrouth cet après-midi un ambassadeur
algérien diplomates syriens
l'ambassadeur de france était présent au
téléphone beaurivage
mais ce dernier messieurs christian le
greffe est rentré à la résidence des
ambassadeurs de l'ambassade de france
sans les otages français
pas de nouvelles et le monsieur chirac
communiste qui se tient constamment
affirmé à l'hôtel matignon a indiqué que
la nouvelle de la libération de deux
otages français n'était malheureusement
pas confirmé on espère peut-être que ces
hautes alpes c'était des conduits vers
damas mais pour l'instant je me
contenterai comme d'habitude dans
chacune de nos éditions de me rappeler
que marcel carton et marcel fontaine
sont détenus depuis de 455 jour que jean
paul kauffmann et michel surya sont
détenus depuis 3 194 jours que l'équipe
d'antenne 2 philippe rochot georges en
scène aurel cornéa jean vidal mada sont
détenus depuis 104 jours et camille sont
de taille des 44 jours de détention en
raison du service minimum la télévision
je viens d'apprendre que le maintien de
l'appel à la grève est fait pour le 25
juin prochain date de demi finale de
coupe du monde en raison du service
minimum
pas d'eau dernier journal à demain 19h30
ce soir
merci